white house correspondent kristen fisher
live on the north lawn with the latest
good evening kristin
good evening brett well the white house
is now clarifying the vice president's
role at the border
less than a week after president biden
announced that she would be the
administration's diplomatic lead
on this effort amid mounting questions
about when vice president kamala harris
would actually take a trip to texas
the white house press secretary says the
vp is not taking the lead
on the administration's response to the
crisis at the border
instead her focus is strictly on
diplomacy with mexico in the three
northern triangle countries
to address root causes of migration and
to oversee the flow of u.s aid to those
countries
the vice president of the united states
will be helping
lead that effort specifically the root
causes not the border there's some
confusion over that
white house press secretary jen saki
says the vice president
has no immediate plans to visit the
border but former president trump says
he plans to take a trip in the next few
weeks as for president biden who was
asked about his predecessor's plans on
sunday
we are putting in place a plan that i
feel very confident about and
and i don't care what the other guy does
u.s customs and border protection is now
expecting this surge in unaccompanied
migrant children
to last at least seven months the white
house press secretary was pressed about
that prediction during the briefing
today
but she again punted to the department
of homeland security
i don't have any predictions those would
certainly come from cbp or the
department of homeland security
but our focus now is on ensuring that we
have enough shelters facilities
to house unaccompanied children more
shelters and facilities means there's a
need for more people to
care for the migrant children housed
inside the need is so great
that last week the biden administration
sent a memo to the heads of multiple
government agencies
asking for civilian federal employees to
volunteer for deployments
of up to 120 days a spokesperson for the
office of personnel management confirms
we're actively working to screen process
and deploy these volunteers
to bolster staff resources at the border
republican senator tom cotton who
visited the border last week
says it's past the point of a crisis
asking federal employees to deploy the
border addressing the symptoms not the
cause
the cause is joe biden opening our
border
still no plans for president biden to
visit the border but he did just make a
surprise trip along with the first lady
to the vietnam veterans memorial
the president's next trip is to
pittsburgh on wednesday
where he is expected to unveil another
multi-trillion dollar spending package
brett
will be following that christian fisher
live on the north lawn kristen thanks